this is Jocko podcast number 371 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening
we are what we pretend to be so we must
be careful of what we pretend to be
there's a little quote from Kurt
Vonnegut
one of my favorite authors ah look
that's kind of a weird thing to say
because I don't have like this big list
of favorite authors but he's one of the
authors that I actually do really like a
lot uh Kurt Vonnegut born and raised in
Indianapolis went to Cornell University
got kicked out of ROTC because he had
bad grades
and he was a little over the top with
his satire the school newspaper so that
kind of tells you what kind of a dude he
was but then he he didn't want to get
drafted so he withdrew from college to
go get uh enlist in the army
1943 got captured during the Battle of
the Bulge
prisoner of war in Dresden of course
this is this I'm just giving you a basic
background if you don't know this stuff
while he was a prisoner of war in
Dresden Dresden got firebombed by the
Allied Forces 25
000 civilians were killed and the place
was just a wasteland and he had survived
he they were being held as prisoners of
war in
this slaughterhouse and he went into
like the meat locker of the
slaughterhouse
which is where the book Slaughterhouse
Five comes from
anyways he survives the war becomes a
reporter
wrote a bunch of really good books very
funny dark humor
uh cat's cradle book Welcome to The
Monkey House Slaughterhouse Five which I
already talked about
but this quote that he he gave which is
we are what we pretend to be so we must
be careful of what we pretend to be
it reminds me of this idea that we've
been talking about for the last two
podcasts and if you haven't listened to
podcast 369 and 370 then just stop and
go listen to those first and then catch
up here
but we've been talking about this idea
of the game
and there's multiple games and you can
go get that information from those other
two podcasts
also kind of reminded me of this idea of
Sam Harris from and I were talking one
time and he said
you can't
pretend to be brave because if you're
scared and you're like well I'm really
scared but I'm gonna pretend to be brave
well and then you go and do Brave stuff
well you're not just pretending you're
actually Brave
but we have so that's kind of along the
same lines somewhat as
be careful what you're pretending to be
because that's what you are
and that's reminded me of what we've
been talking about you have to be
careful of what game or what games you
play
because you
can quite possibly become those games
more importantly the game that you play
can become your life
so we did those last two podcasts about
this 369 370.
and we were getting a bunch of feedback
and questions and
comments and whatnot and so I reached
out on social media on the interwebs to
get some get some of those questions get
some of that feedback on those two
podcasts and I want to go through those
now just because a bunch of people want
you know we had had some Stones we
didn't turn over yet had some angles we
hadn't seen so first one out of the gate
from Sarah Armstrong
what's up Sarah Armstrong she said
observation
if your win involves the participation
of other people make sure you are not
setting yourself up for disappointment
by setting unrealistic expectations for
others yes this is true
this is factual
that we did an early podcast where I
talked about the fact that I don't have
a bunch of high expectations for other
people yeah
because if you said other people with a
bunch of high expectations you're
counting on them it's there's a decent
chance you're going to get let down and
why do that
why not take ownership of what's going
on yourself so that's my recommendation
and Sarah Armstrong is right here we
can't you can't count on others
look they can be part of the plan but
you better have a backup and you better
you better not have a single point of
failure be relying on some other human
because you're there's a decent chance
you're setting yourself up as Sarah says
for disappointment
so don't expect too much if anything
from others someone else next one this
is from from Bizzle Fitness
I don't know if I'm gonna cover all
these weird uh handles
that people have different call signs uh
really enjoyed these last two I'd like
to hear your thoughts on two related
aspects to this pitfalls and opportunity
costs that's number one and two
balancing multiple games
easy example the folks that get old and
either wish they had worked less or
spent more time with their family or
those on Other Extreme who wish they had
done more with their lives yep there you
go
so first for the pitfalls
and opportunity costs
and as I went through these
we're going to come into
we're going to start heading into a
common theme in a lot of these questions
and that is
investment and return on investment
right so
a pitfall in any game that you play is
you can lose
so when you get on the field or you
engage in a game there's a chance you're
going to lose so what that means is you
have to be careful with what you invest
into that game and you have to head your
bets and you have to have contingency
plans now what's interesting about this
is like the whole idea of
like 100 commitment which is sort of a
like do you hear this about Seal
training
like you have to have no backup plan or
Officer and a Gentleman your officer
I got nothing else that's kind of a
positive thing like I have no backup
plan oh I'm gonna start a business and
I'm just I'm putting everything every
every penny I have into it and if it
fails I'm just done I'm gonna be in the
streets right and therefore I'm gonna go
extra hard to make it work
if you have to do that to yourself
psychologically okay
you don't have to do that to yourself
psychologically
and you can set yourself up to
have a backup plan if they're your
primary plan like SEAL training there's
a decent chance that you're not going to
make it through it
because you got hurt because you got
injured because you got sick because you
didn't you thought you were tougher than
you already quit all those things
happened they happened to 80 of people
that go there so having a backup plan
as long as you don't use that as you're
out now look if you're going to use that
as you're out yeah it's going to let you
down if you're going to work hard in
your business but at the end of the day
you're like you know what I can still
just go back to my old job and I still
have my house so I'm just gonna go back
to my old job and go move back and just
continue on as opposed to being like no
I'm gonna gut through it because I have
no nowhere else to go you can see the
dichotomy there yeah
I would hope that you have the internal
fortitude to push on and not just hit
the escape hatch if it comes up right
what did I hurt some weird experiment
I forget where I heard it
like they were drowning was this a
Jordan Peterson the other night they
were drown if you take a chicken or they
or a rabbit or something and they would
drown it
and
uh
they would hold it they would make it
tread water that's what it was they
would make a rabbit tread water and I I
heard this on a podcast or something I
think it I think anyways I heard it on a
podcast
you take the the rabbit and you put it
in the water or a rat I think there's a
rat you put in the rat in the water and
it can tread water and it Treads water
trying to live trying to live trying to
live and then right as it goes under for
the last time
you pull it out of the water
and that takes about 15 minutes there
you go
and then if you do it with those same
rats again
they'll tread water for like it was
something like 60 hours
because they think at any minute they're
going to get pulled out of the water but
if you take a fresh rat it's still only
going to make it 15 minutes so
if you if you have the type of
Personality where you're just going to
give up and go back to the easy way then
I get it you know I don't maybe you
don't have a a backup plan because you
want to trap yourself where you have to
keep going forward
that's a real thing man that's a real
thing wait to that rats experiment what
did that what was that conclusion there
that like the conclusion you got some
hope you're just gonna hang on over
until yeah hope will make you hang on I
hope we'll make you hang on that's crazy
yeah it is yes but it totally makes
sense right yeah and almost at the same
time which is like equally if not more
significant the lack of Hope will make
you just be like hey I'm kind of done
bro like there ain't no getting out of
this yeah like you literally have plenty
of energy left to stick it out for you
know however long but the lack of Hope
just pushes you right under yeah so uh
to be honest with you
my my lean is towards like yeah you
should have contingency plans you should
have backup plans you should hedge your
bets you say oh yeah I'm going to try
this new business but I'm not going to
quit my old job until I've got it up and
running
now there's probably a subset of people
that can't do that and they're like the
rat that just is going to give up after
15 minutes you know what I mean and
they're just done yeah don't you feel
that like if you do if you draw the
parallel like where someone I don't know
what were you talking about like
starting a business starting a business
okay I want to leave my job I'm going to
start a new business Yeah so basically
the equivalent kind of I guess in a way
is yeah you start your new business you
buy the website
and then you know you start it in
whatever way but you hit a roadblock so
the hardcore that you don't have that
hope you literally don't see it going
anywhere like literally in your mind
regardless of how it would you know like
that'll that'll kind of do the same
thing as like oh yeah just drowned just
I'm just gonna drop myself because I
lost the whole stuff you know rather
than oh this is just getting really hard
or you know this obstacle is like it's
big and I don't have the energy you know
it's more about oh yeah I don't see it
going you've already quit your other job
then maybe that pushes you right maybe
you have you you have no other choice
it's a little bit different because it's
like you have no other choice it's not
about Hope anymore it's like you have to
know what else you're gonna do yeah so I
get it that is a pitfall is the pitfall
of all these different games if you play
these games you can lose and that means
you need to in my opinion
don't over invest this is why we have
the iterative decision making prog
process this is why we make Little Steps
we don't just go you know what I want to
start my own business quit my job give
up my health insurance for my family
can't pay the rent next month whatever
but I'm gonna start my new I'm selling
widgets we're gonna go for it and you're
gonna work hard to sell those widgets
because you got a family feed and you
want to pay your mortgage but guess what
there's a chance that that thing just
was a bad plan and no one wants your
stupid widgets and now you're out of a
job you don't have health insurance for
your kids so why not take iterative
steps
um the other thing is the opportunity
costs for sure
how much can you invest in winning a
game right how much can you actually
afford what and then what's the ROI
when you're playing this game instead of
that game what's the ROI on the game
that you choose yeah
and is it worth it what if you win that
game what if you lose that game you have
to track risk and you have to track Roi
this is stuff that you need to think
about you need to think about the risk
in the game
and what the ROI is should you win
and then what the cost is should you
lose
and this is to do with anything look
we're talking about the game this is
anything anything that you are planning
on doing you're planning on getting in a
relationship okay cool what's the ROI
what's the risk
oh she comes from a great background
she's got a squared away education she
comes from a stable family she's got a
very even temperament okay cool
that sounds pretty positive when you
start seeing red flags in there
now United States are saying okay well
there's some risk here there's some risk
there
so think about those things
and make logical decisions but
when you make logical decisions you
still have to put emotions into the
calculus because if you're doing if
you're if you're going to start this new
business and you're totally passionate
about it and you love it and you might
make less money but you're you love
doing it that might be better
then
you you're making more money but you
hate your freaking life you hate your
job 12 hours a day you hate
so you have to take emotions and put
them into the calculus
so there you go the the other question
there was how to balance multiple games
that we're all playing we'll prioritize
next cube right
and again what's the ROI and the risk
per game in all these different games
there's some games that you really have
to pay attention to
what do you want
what do you actually want
what is actually going to give you
fulfillment
and you can't lie to yourself because
there's people that lie to themselves
about what's going to make them happy
about what is going to give them
fulfillment and if you lie to yourself
for throughout your life if that's when
you end up on your deathbed again going
back to Bizzle fitness's question that's
when you go to your deathbed and you're
like man I didn't care about all this
money or man I didn't care about what
you know this uh
going up the chain of command in some in
the military or in some company or
getting you know I invested all my time
into Jiu Jitsu and like I knew I wasn't
gonna be a champion I wasted all
whatever I don't know what it is
seems like a hard one
but but you know you know what I'm
saying yeah it's true there's people
that there's people that reach a point
in Jitsu they're like oh you know I I
don't want to do this anymore yeah that
happens yeah yeah fully and I guess with
Jiu Jitsu I felt like and there was I
went through mental stuff like that too
where
I felt like the whole reason
that I liked Jiu Jitsu is like to be
able to get into a competition like in
almost like like a combat Sport and win
it made me feel good about myself kind
of a thing and then after like a few you
know like years of computers with the
psychological reveal
but after years of competing and then
when I got into like
my career and then eventually kind of
got married or whatever I was like wait
you kind of got married
I'm gonna give you a chance to say that
correctly so that we don't get anything
from I was gonna say the person that you
kind of got married to I was gonna say I
kind of got um other responsibility so
to speak even though like Jiu Jitsu is a
responsibility that's why I say kinda
anyway you get married you start having
like kids and stuff it puts it into
perspective like hey sure I'm always
going to go to Jujitsu but why don't I
feel the same way and I'm like oh wait
it puts into perspective there are more
important things than winning Jiu Jitsu
tournaments so you looked at the ROI
yeah of yeah you know training seven
days a week three hours a day
and you were and and the ROI of
investing time and effort into your
family and the ROI of investing time and
effort into your career and this is
exactly what we're talking about you had
to prioritize an execute you know what
seven days a week three hours a day
and my Roi on that is I'll feel good
about a competition yeah but the ROI of
investing in my career is I can get
money I can get stability I can take
care of my family and by the way that's
the other thing my family there's the
ROI of you know raising my kids and the
smile on my wife's face all those things
and you weigh those out and you're
honest with yourself and you prioritize
those things in the correct way so that
when you're on your deathbed you're not
like man I really wish I would have
trained Jujitsu more or you're like boy
I'm glad I won that tournament yeah you
know even though my wife left me yeah
and my kids don't know me I'm really
happy I won that tournament and I got a
coral belt in Jiu Jitsu when I was 68.
yeah that was that was kind of the
thought really where it went through
this
you went through this with your uh with
with these things in your life you
actually did this protocol and we talked
about this we talked about that being
honest with yourself that was sort of
the underlying theme of I think I think
370 the the last one was like you have
to be honest with yourself about these
games and in this podcast as I read
through these questions the specific
thing is you need to be honest yourself
about the investment you're willing to
make and what the return is and is it
worth it and is it what you really want
yeah because if it's not
you know I've seen this happen with
Fighters too like Fighters reach a
certain point where they say you know
what I mean like I just
I'm I I don't want to do eight week
camps where I can't see my family and
God whatever happens with people in the
military they're like you know what I
I've done my 10 years I'm not committed
to the job anymore I don't want to do it
anymore and they get out they move on to
something else the ROI they have to be
honest with themselves I've also seen
people lie to themselves yeah about
these types of things and by the time
they get out of the military they
realize that they were pursuing
something because they were basically
caught in that ecosystem can we talked
about that on one of the other podcasts
like man that's so true the other thing
that weighs into this like just to just
to kind of get precise on what you just
said you knew you actually weren't going
to be better than everyone at Jiu Jitsu
you weren't going to be the world
champion no you're gonna be good you're
gonna be good at a particular you being
the top three or five in in a gym you
weren't going to be the number one even
in that particular gym and you
definitely weren't gonna be number one
in the state of California or certainly
not in the world if you would have had
that may be potential now also the ROI
becomes oh it's a little better Roi I
can actually be a champion I can
actually start a school I can have
whatever you can make a living from it
now there's other things that come out
of it you weren't in that situation oh
yeah so and that's a good point because
you don't really well then again I don't
know I can only speak for myself but I
didn't really think about that until I
got my eyes kind of opened where I'm
like oh wait there's all this other
stuff that I can be like
kind of I could see a path to legitimate
success over here but then in Jiu Jitsu
if I even like think about it like that
which I never really did I just was like
I liked training and winning and then
doing the tournament or whatever but
then if I look at like a more a
long-term path you're right I was like
yeah I'm not gonna prove I'm not even
close to these like the real dudes you
know so I'm like oh why would I do this
nice thing about having Dean Lister in
the gym where you're like bro this guy
and Dean Lister you know he was number
one in the world at certain times but a
lot of times he's getting beat by other
guys so you're thinking well this guy's
destroying me so where am I I'm gonna be
like
third or fourth or fifth in my gym yeah
and keep in mind I'm in my 30s at this
time so let's face it you know but the
point is I was I didn't my eyes weren't
even open to that it was just like it
was part habit part payoff going to the
gym and learning cool stuff or whatever
but will you just like how you said that
ecosystem you get blinded by just that
ecosystem because you're just in it you
know and then so other things opened my
eyes or whatever and then you can see
you know for me the Jujitsu is just a ro
the ROI on Jiu Jitsu is the
personal like the good feeling when I
get done training yeah and especially
when I kind of go to war like I'm having
Wars on the mat it feels good get done
like you just know you pushed yeah you
you got tapped you tapped whatever it
doesn't matter but you you you you
struggled you went to war in in in that
Arena which makes sense BJ Penn actually
said on this podcast it's called Mind
pump he was on this podcast he's uh he
was like I I train for my mental health
and I was like oh that's so true because
really that's essentially what you said
it's like you go in it's like it's
therapy in so many different ways you
it's the kind it's so good where like
just the activity and I found that even
when I go and I don't have heart
training or I do have heart training to
me it's all the same at the end I mean
look if you have a bunch of super duper
easy trainings in a in a row and you're
like Frick I wish that okay there's that
but you go to jiu jitsu unless you get
injured which I had before but if unless
you get injured you go home you can feel
better 100 even if you really didn't
feel like going which is a lot of the
time but if you get yourself it's like
any workout you know but Jiu Jitsu has
those extra elements of like I don't
know something that like
fulfills you or whatever yeah no my they
made that uh they made that video at
origin of my daughter talking about it
and she was just like once she realized
how good it made her feel yeah but
mentally that's when she was like oh I
can I should do this all the time yeah
and it happens when you withdraw from it
you're like well I don't feel that good
and also you do you're like oh yeah so
that's what I feel like yeah
so the ROI on that level for me Jujitsu
this just this just this just devolved
into just appeared discussion but it was
everything yeah it applies to checking
the ROI on the game whether that game is
you're gonna get focused on getting
involved in uh you know your your
thing at work like where does it go
that someone people get caught up in
they get caught up in like oh I'm in
this job I'm in this Corporation and I'm
gonna make it I'm gonna make it to the
next level I'll make it the next level
okay that's cool as long as that Roi is
real as long as you're like oh if you're
like hey I'm just doing this because the
pay is great and I can take care of my
family and I'm gonna get promoted and
get more money okay cool cool work hard
and that all works out if you're
thinking oh I wanna
I want people to calm I want to be the
VP right I want to be the EVP
and then you think that's going to make
you feel better and if it does cool
that's fine that's awesome like hey you
Rose up you we're in a big company you
were running a big department you had a
lot of responsibility you're taking care
of that that is totally legit yeah as
long as you're telling yourself the
truth if you're lying to yourself that's
when it becomes problematic that's one
thing that's so cool about Echelon front
is I work with so many different people
like there's people that do you can name
it
and they're totally into it man and it's
awesome like I want I love to work with
people that whatever they're doing
whether they're digging ditches but
they're doing it safely and they're
doing you know doing huge contracts and
it's awesome they're running big
companies and it's cool they love doing
that stuff or they're you know making a
product or they're providing a service
but they're into it they're in the right
game yeah and I hope that if you're
listening you can do an honest
assessment of yourself and make sure
that that game that you're in is the
right game for you
and if you're doing something that you
don't really care about my clients if
you don't care about the people you're
that you're serving or you're providing
service from that's not a good indicator
if you're working with people you don't
really like or you don't really want to
take care of that's not a good indicator
so be honest with yourself and make sure
that the game that you're in from a work
perspective is the right game
that's a lot more common problem than
I'm into a you know Jiu Jitsu as an
example but any hobby that you're into
like you invest a bunch of money into
archery
you wouldn't invest a bunch of money
unless it was unless you liked it unless
the ROI was good yeah so the hobbies are
a little bit easier to just I'm not
going to do that yeah actually the
hobbies are the opposite where you
should be doing it but you're not you
you know you you know you should be
training Jitsu you know you should be
lifting weights you know you should be
running or doing whatever thing it is
because you know it makes you feel good
but you say oh you know
right you forget about the ROI you
forget about the return you only think
about the investment well you know I got
to get up early and do this before I go
to work and that's kind of a pain you
only focus on the investment you don't
focus on the return the return is your
health and that's what you should focus
that's why measuring the investment and
measuring the return on investment of
what you do in the game whatever game it
is that's why I'm trying to get you to
pay attention to them
all right
next one Carter Royce I guess Carter
hoist maybe if he's from Brazil uh if
everyone on a team has a different
overall Life game slash goal how do you
work to align these different
perspectives into one that benefits the
overall team and this is a work
relationships Community here's the
here's the cool thing about this
Living Well doing good and helping each
other
generally speaking helps helps ourselves
as well it General so when you're
talking about interacting with other
people whether it's at work whether it's
in your family whether it's in your
community if you help other people it's
going to help you
and if everyone recognizes that then
we're all aligned so if
if I help Echo
if if you and I work together
and if you work hard and so you provide
a good service to our clients
I benefit you benefit I benefit and we
both know that at Echelon front Okay so
take Echelon front we got a bunch of
instructors there
the better each individual instructor
does right the better JP does the better
life does the better I do the better
Dave does the better each individual
instructor does
providing the service for the client the
better that individual does
and the better Echelon front us
because people call back say we want JP
to come again yeah he's great we want
him to come and do a four-day Workshop
like that's what happens so guess what
JP makes more money Echelon front makes
more money the client gets taken care of
so that's the way it is with most in
your family oh you're
your kid is you you take you you get
your kid to study you know you talk to
you explain to them the why they study
hard they get better grades they get
better grades
that's beneficial not just for you you'd
be like hey Mike it's a straight A
student right you get to brag cool but
also your kid gets a better life they
get into a better school they get a
better job all that stuff happens the
family's doing better because now I
don't have to rely my kid's not relying
on me for that for that you know kicking
down some some money because they don't
have a good job
how does alignment roll into that
because like I was asking like everyone
has a different overall gaming goal but
well what I'm saying is
if you're part of a team because he's
talking about an individual a team
whether that team is a family a company
if we you know at my family
if I say Hey listen we got to do a
better job with not spending so much
money we're wasting money on this we're
wasting money on that people are going
buying a cup of coffee that cost three
dollars it's hurting us
we need to tighten it up so when I say
that to the whole family the whole
family realizes oh I need to spend less
money guess what we end up with more
Financial Security because we're not
wasting a bunch of money and that means
we can you know get that new roof that
we need because our roof is leaking yeah
like this is what happens
so when you're all working together it's
very rare
that something that helps the individual
doesn't help the team right
because because then what why are you
part of why is there a team yeah teams
are meant to achieve a goal
whether that's a business whether that's
a family whether that's a sports team
you know if if Echo if you and I are
part of the same company
and you and I are supposed to make
widgets and you make 10 a day and I only
make five a day
is the fact that you made more than me
is actually good for you because you're
going to get your bonus but it's also
good for me
I don't want to like undermine you
because then all of a sudden we're not
getting as many of our widgets made and
now we don't have as many to sell and
now some other place can come in and get
a market share from us and that's a
problem yeah so for this
when you when you climb the ladder of
alignment which I talk about a lot at
Echelon front
you and I might be competing to make
widgets right you won't you you and I
are getting a bonus based on how many we
make and whoever makes more gets a
better bonus we're competing yeah but as
soon as we go up one level
up the up the ladder of alignment and I
say
hey I don't want to actually like steal
some of your parts for your widget so
you can't make as many or so your
widgets don't meet the quality right and
now someone out in the marketplace buys
it it doesn't work right and now they
complain they put it on Yelp and now our
sales go down yeah so when you go up and
say hey look even though we're competing
against each other see who can make more
widgets
and still maintain quality
even though we're competing against each
other if you go up one level we're
actually working together because if we
provide good widgets and we make a lot
of them there'll be more to sell we can
lower the price a little bit which means
we can sell even more we can drive some
other people out of the market like
that's what's happening yeah so climb
the ladder of alignment a little bit go
to a higher place where it's like oh we
are on the same team yeah you I always
listen to that when you say climbing the
ladder of alignment because you know
people that's like one of the main
questions that people ask you in my when
I I mean in my experience I'd be like
hey what do you do when we're not
aligned and this person has little
separate agendas right and so I'm
thinking wait a second yeah that's
obviously a common problem so why is it
always that like well not that simple
but why is it always
like you always have that same solution
and it makes perfect sense so I'm still
thinking why the hell is it still a
problem like that much because people
mistake agendas for alignment
they they mistake the fact that you and
I are competing to who can make more
widgets they mistake that fact that
we're competing and we're actually
trying to go against each other with the
fact that if you go up a few levels
we're actually both trying to do the
same thing and move in the same
direction yeah yeah I realized slowly
but truly the jam up comes when someone
invokes their short-term agenda at the
expense of the long term right agenda
even for themselves and by the way and
when that happens so I steal some of
your parts yeah and I mess them up and I
put them back in your bucket of the
widgets you're assembling yeah so I can
look better so I look better yeah and
all someone needs to do is pull me aside
and say hey jonker we got you know we
saw that we saw what you did
let me ask you this Jocko if you know
someone buys one of the parts that Echo
made one of the widgets that Echo made
and doesn't work what's that going to do
to our reputation oh now they're going
to want not going to want to buy the
ones that you made either oh now we're
not selling as many of these things oh
now in order to cover our margin we got
to raise our prices oh now that we've
raised our prices the competitor comes
in and is looking even better with an
even lower price oh we're getting driven
see what I'm saying all you have to do
is pull the thread on it and you realize
that
occasion it's so rare and usually this
when I say it's so rare that people are
actually not aligned yeah once you go
high enough look we can be aligned even
in a sealants like you have you have
Seth in in uh Delta platoon and life in
Charlie platoon they're competitive
against each other you know they both
want we only got you know seven of the
new weapon sites the new high-speed
weapons that's life wants them all Seth
wants them all
and if they're gonna steal them from
each other
that's bad but if I say hey guys who's
got a mission that more requires these
sites yeah and life's like well you know
Seth's doing this these patrols over in
this area that's further ranges that you
could probably use them oh okay as soon
as you go up a level the problem gets
solved occasionally very rarely
Echo
actually wants to start his own widget
business so he's doing things that
legitimately are not aligned he's making
parts that are not he's making widgets
that suck and they're gonna go out in
the market we're gonna have a bad
reputation he's gonna go up I started to
echo's widgets and we make the highest
quality so occasionally you can have
people that are truly not aligned at the
top of the alignment ladder of alignment
they're not aligned this is what I
always ask people I ask companies like
oh okay who here doesn't want the
company to be profitable no one raises
their hands who here doesn't want to
take care of the people on your team no
one raise your hand who here doesn't
want to take care of your customer no
one raises their hand so there all of a
sudden everyone's aligned everybody
wants to make money everybody wants to
take care of their team and everyone's
take care of the customers everyone's
aligned no one goes like well I'd
actually like to screw over the
customers or like hey I actually I
actually want my team to to be in a bad
bad position or I want the company to
lose money yeah that's not happening
same thing in war
what do we want to do kill bad guys keep
our guys safe and win the war okay
who here wants to get their guys killed
no one who here doesn't want to kill the
bad guys no one who here wants us to
lose no one so we're aligned you might
be thinking we should attack from this
direction I'm thinking we should attack
from a different direction but one of us
is right one of us wrong it's not that
we disagree on what we're trying to
achieve so we're aligned we just have
different ideas
and that's all there is to it and it's
the same thing here when it comes to
these various games that we're playing
yeah that
um and JP tells a good story about this
but that that's a good point where it's
like yeah you might have two different
ideas but once you kind of realize how
aligned you really are you start to be
like wait a second let's really hash out
who has the better idea whether it's you
or me or whatever but it puts it into
perspective that much more so and that's
what happened to JP according to his
story about uh you guys you know when he
came back you know he has all these like
important missions and all this like big
huge impact he's made he comes back and
then he has to be like an instructor
which he thought was like not the it was
like a misuse of his his value or
whatever it was a danger to society
there's a danger to Bud students I can
guarantee you that yeah JP in ramadi as
the lead sniper and then whatever two
weeks later he's like standing in front
of Bud students that's not a good
transition up here for JP Nella 22 years
old
you realize that's literally when I met
JP oh really like right when he got back
yeah that's when I met him for the first
time with kids where did you meet him
that's at Sushi yeah he was like yeah
but um but he makes a great point where
he's like he was so mad he didn't even
admits like I was so mad I should be
over there doing this you know kill him
back and he talks to you one time and
you're like hey that was your mission
then this is your mission now we're
fighting we're you're doing this you're
gonna train these guys so we the best
you possibly possibly possibly can so
they can be good enough to go over and
we never have to go to funeral again
boom just like that put back into
perspective alignment alignment revealed
so there you go
um there you go carter hope that helps
next one easy money dude hell yeah Jack
how do you identify what games are worth
playing or games to avoid again this is
this is a study in return on investment
no and it's not just return it's return
on investment so it's what are you gonna
have to put into this thing and what can
we possibly get out of it and what are
the risks involved
and then you just have to be honest with
yourself
just be honest with you sir you're
looking at some some game
want to get involved with a girl want to
start a new business want to get
involved in a club
you know there's like uh you know rotary
club or whatever I want to get involved
in that thing
want to get involved in some volunteer
organization whatever it is what do you
have to put into it what's the return
going to be and what are the risks
involved
then be honest with yourself
[Applause]
did you know that Seinfeld had nine
episodes and they were like at the top
of the charts and then he just stopped
what do you mean had nine episodes or
not episode sorry 1960s yeah and it was
number one and he just stopped and
they're like what the hell they wanted
him they were gonna pay him crazy
amounts of money for a 10th season
so why didn't he do it because of this
he identified the game worth playing
because he looked back he said I'm not
married I have no kids nothing all I'm
doing is this show no matter how
successful it was like that's not worth
it anymore there was my life the games
I'm playing there you go perfect example
he had to look at it he's got this game
he knows what the investment is it's his
time it's his effort and he's putting
everything into it and he's already
achieved he's gotten what he what the
return that he's gotten and he's like
you know what I got enough money
I got enough Fame I got enough credit
you know street cred from who gives
street cred comedians cred or something
I don't know well it would it's
literally one of the if not the most
successful sitcom of all time sure so
that's like that's a big deal to be like
Oh I'm done
did you watch that show a lot yes like
all of it yes
yes okay pretty good I think so yes
but it relates to like all the little
everyday things in life yeah it's pretty
good I've watched I've watched probably
I've watched some of them probably like
20 of them or something like that but if
there's nine Seasons I'm really not even
scratching the surface but that's a
great example she looked at it measured
the ROI
and said okay cool I'm done and there
you go good good uh
good metaphor there next one is from
that Jake denim Denham something like
that how did you learn about real estate
investing
um
a guy told me a guy a guy in the SEAL
Teams
that I worked for was like yeah you know
I bought I bought houses
and they increased in value over time I
don't know how he said it specifically
but that but that's basically what he
said to me he probably said something
like you know I bought this house eight
years ago he's older than me I bought
this house eight years ago for 150 Grand
it's worth like 400 Grand now and I must
have been like like the slow turning
things coming together and the other
thing in this one I did remember
he was like because he rented these
houses out he's like someone else is
paying my mortgage
and that seemed very smart and I
realized that I was one of those people
that was paying someone else's mortgage
and I didn't like that so
started buying houses you know one at a
time buy a house yeah as soon as I had
that house was kind of settled in and
then bought another one and just tried
to hold on to him and that's what I did
[Music]
um
yeah that's how I that's how I learned
about real estate investing I took some
really simplistic phrases from a dude
that was telling me what was up and just
saw the game I saw the game that's let's
bring it back to this right I saw that
this guy had bought a house for 100
grand and now it was worth 300 Grand in
like a seven year period but more that
seemed cool more important I realized
that someone else was paying for that
house yeah
and I realized where I was on the board
on the game board right I was paying
rent bro I was paying for someone else's
house how would you feel if you're like
at a bar
and like you're sitting there drinking
your beer
and then the bill comes over and you're
signing it and you're signing there's
some other good dude he's having like
hors d'oeuvres he's having bottle
service bottle service and they're like
yeah
here's his bill you'd be pissed yeah you
wouldn't stand for it but we stand for
that with when it comes to where we live
we basically stand for it so once I
realize we're out that's a good example
of oh
there's a game I don't even know I was
part of the game I didn't know I was
part of the game yeah I thought that's
what was happening yeah you gave me the
bill I signed it I didn't know this guy
was over here with bottle service yeah
you know I'm paying for his bottle
service that's what you're doing you're
buying someone a house when you're
paying rent look are there times we got
to rent sure you go to you take a job
you're in a job for a short period of
time you're only gonna be in this city
for a year and it's you don't know
what's gonna happen the market I'm not
saying go run out and buy a house
tomorrow you need to understand what's
happening but if you know you're going
to be somewhere for a longer period of
time
yeah and you can afford to buy a house
go buy a house
so I realized that that's what realized
that's what made me realize it's one of
the earlier games
that I checked into
um another question from him is how to
know when you're playing the wrong game
and it's time to quit
or switch games okay
Roi right
uh measure the ROI what are you getting
out of this
if you're gonna get a lot out of it but
it's a lot of effort okay well is it
worth the effort is it worth the
investment time money leadership Capital
whatever the thing is family is it going
to be worth it
or is it not
and so you when you figure out the risks
and you figure out the investment and
you figure out the return you may or may
not get based on those risks okay then
you can make a decision
we also now what's interesting about
this question is
we're in the game he's saying you're
playing the wrong game so now what we
have to do is we have to do an honest
assessment of our
trajectory in this game right how well
am I doing
am I making progress you know how now in
the UFC when you watch the UFC they have
the odds
they show the odds after each round oh
damn yeah so now that's a new thing I
don't know how new it is but it's a few
years old but
like oh Echo really did great in that
last round against Jocko his odds of
winning now just went up oh damn oh
Jocko just came back and had a great
round and plus Deco was like stunned at
the end of the round it looks like he
was gonna get knocked out he got Saved
by the Bell oh Jocko's odds just went up
for the last round a lot
you have to do an assessment and see
where you're at right
and see what is your trajectory of
what's happening it's kind of like what
you said you did with your Jiu Jitsu
career you're like okay I'm 30 whatever
you're 34 years old I'm the seventh best
guy in my gym which is not bad but let's
face it we're one gym okay and
I'm making progress but so is everybody
else
okay where am I at where am I going with
this
same thing with a job you know okay I've
been at the same job I've been in this
this position for for four years
I haven't been promoted in the last
three years
I don't have a good relationship with my
boss
this does not seem like it's a good fit
for me so you've got to do an honest
assessment of your trajectory
and
make a decision
uh
one thing that you can do is you can
kind of mitigate risk right this is a
story I've told a few times but Greg
McIntyre sure Great Train really great
at a certain point Greg's a badass
he's a freaking great wrestler his Jiu
Jitsu solid he's great athlete he's a
good boxer
and he was kind of he was he was
starting in the MMA scene
and he had like he had real legit
potential in MMA because he's a great
wrestler tough as Nails strong for I
mean he's freaking 155 pounder he's
strong as hell
so Greg Trane actually asked me and this
was like probably 15 or 20 years ago
this is a long time ago this is probably
20 years ago he was like what do you
think I should do
should I just dedicate my whole life
right now to MMA
or should I keep training but also he
wanted to get a degree he wanted to
become an x-ray technician that's what
he is right yep and I was like listen
bro
how many hours a day can you train
legitimately and I I said can you train
16 hours a day and he said no I said no
one can train 16 hours a day how many if
you really train hard how many hours a
day can you train including recovery
like the whole nine yards he's like I
don't know maybe four or five right
that's like training conditioning
recovery maybe you do six maybe you do
six
okay you're gonna work eight hours a day
you sleep eight hours a day
that's 16 hours right you got plenty of
time to train and you can still have a
backup to MMA and in case you go to
wrestling practice tomorrow and blow
your knee out which can happen on any
given day
and so he played both games you know and
and he he you know he had a good run at
MMA he also ran into some problems that
were tough to deal with
and so
he mitigated the risk played more than
one game at the same time
and when the MMA thing dried up guess
what he still had a cool career making
good money beautiful family taking care
of them house like the whole nine yards
so that's a situation where he didn't
necessarily quit the other game
but he he
mitigated the risk by playing multiple
games at the same time yeah
so there's this thing called the sunk
cost fallacy it's like I got it in one
of these questions for sure yeah because
that's a factor and I'm thinking back to
my bouncer days where you know I had you
know kind of you know I spent a few
years there and like and I remember one
time my brother Jade he goes he goes hey
you ever thought about getting another
job and I was offended I was like bro
all the stuff I learned all the friends
that I made all this stuff like
basically all these commitments that
I've made over the years and and
accumulated all these little you know
results or whatever kind of kept me in
there kind of like hey if I get it if I
start all over it's kind of like what
about all that what I put into yeah that
given the circumstances and I'll tell
you you probably just gave the most
shallow example of sunk cost of fallacy
because honestly yeah because if you
think about it I mean what is that
really like you didn't you look you you
made some friends you had a moved up the
chain where you were now like the shift
lead or something like that which
probably took you six months or
something
when you get to people that are in legit
sunk oh it's like oh I went to I went to
undergrad I got my pre-law I went to law
school I did my freaking time as a clerk
and went up through the chain of command
and now I'm a lawyer it's been eight
years I've invested 450 000 and I
freaking hate it you know I hate this
job yeah
that sunk cost yeah where they go dude
do I really walk away from this right
now that's where people have to that's
where the sunk cost makes people stick
to the same crappy job that they don't
like for a long period of time which I
recommend definitely watching out for
well you well you know the the common
example of sunk cost is the movie
theater one which is more shallow than
mine even do you you ought to go for the
movie yeah you go to the movie you get
go through halfway three quarters and
you're like I might as well finish it
you know I'm yeah I'm here you know what
I'm gonna do walk out of the movie I
already paid you know that you know but
no bruh walk out I what I do in the
movie sucks I just go to sleep bro I
feel so like comfortable sleeping in
theaters have you when my kids were
little we'd go to see like one of those
kids movies oh yeah yeah and look
there's some really good kid kids movies
but a lot of times they just they're
just not good
uh Incredibles yeah it's good The
Incredibles I like Moana that was a good
one man Moana I don't think I made it
through that one bruh come on
I don't know if I made there's a lot a
lot of them there's some cones for sure
yeah so but most of them are going to
sleep and they're walking out of a lot
of movies well that's different so like
you walked out of a lot of movies I
walked out on the one with Angelina
Jolie and Ethan Hawk
back at that I don't even yeah I even
forget what it was I remember he there
was something
it didn't seem like you're kind of you
know but but keep in mind I think when
you walk out of the like you can't just
tell the kids hey I'm bored with this
kids movie so you know so of course
falling asleep that's like yeah that's a
good it's kind of a joke in my family
that if like when we when they would
know yeah he was going to sleep
snore and embarrass him yes sir so again
this boils back to we have to pay
attention to risk investment and return
on investment and we have to do an
honest assessment if you're in the game
you gotta check your trajectory honestly
and look you Echo looked at his
trajectory and said it you know what I'm
kind of a shift lead now I got these
friends I could get I can get beer you
know whenever I want I'm head of the
line privileges that these other clubs I
kind of right but he had to look at a
longer term trajectory like okay where
am I going to be in five years and all
you have to do is meet that one person
that's like been a been in some position
that you're in but they've been there
for 17 years yeah and you're like so
there's like one more element involved
in that exact thing right there so
you know when I started over there at
the club I was 23. just turned 23. so
you know you see a guy who's like 40.
you're like oh well I'm only doing this
like two decades from now you know like
bro I'll be you know whatever you don't
even think it's so far ahead but then
when you uh after a while you get old
actually it's not like Ford it's like
you see a guy who's 30. yeah I'm not
gonna beat that that's like seven years
or forever it's like a third of my life
right yeah what's he doing here yeah and
yeah to be honest you don't even apply
it to yourself because that's just him
and too bad I mean I guess cool up to
you that's your life you know whatever
and then you start reaching 28 29 and
remember back wait a second I was
looking at that 130 and that's next year
so you're like dang that's when it hits
you yeah for sure
that's real that's when you realized you
were uh stationary you were running on a
treadmill that wasn't getting you
anywhere um in a certain Lane you were
in the wrong game I was in the wrong
game but here's the thing though like I
don't want to paint this picture like it
was all [__] because to be honest like
I'm I learned so much which I didn't
even realize by the way I learned so
much just dealing with people under
certain types of circumstances you're
like oh you know like but yes like after
a while you kind of hit the wall in that
regard where you're like well as far as
a career because really when you reach
30s that's like if you're not in it
you're kind of like looking out for one
you know did you ever think about
opening your own club yeah and then what
happened with that
is just a thought you know
it just didn't even yeah it didn't
formulate well me and Sir started dating
then you know when you have like a
girlfriend who has a well I don't know
in my case I had a girlfriend who had
like a for real job and she was making
like for real money like adult money you
know what was she doing Property
Management oh check so you kind of
compare it you know I was like yeah what
I'm gonna open a nightclub and be up all
night still you know and I gotta wake up
at like 11 noon meanwhile you know I'm
like 35 40 years old doing that all the
time like as a routine I'm like which is
would be cool but I just contrasted it
too again it's very important that you
were able to detach and do an assessment
and look at the game of like nightclub
ownership and what does that entail it
means I got to be there like you looked
at the game and you had a good
comparison to look at Sarah's game and
be like oh look we're gonna be playing
two different wildly different games
that's if the Venn diagram doesn't
overlap very much like we'll see each
other for actually won't even see each
other at night because she comes home
you're at the club okay yeah like a
couple of nights only yeah so you
measured the trajectory the ROI the
possibilities and you saw it it wasn't
good yeah good job Echo Charles
next question is from Levi mix I don't
know Levick mix he says how do you play
the game and trust that you're able to
make competent decisions that are
congruent with your growth for example
I've grown an almost unfathomable ways
over the last year but I still have
mindsets from who I previously was when
making incompetent choices
I think what you need to do is take a
step back in a beautiful way and I'm
probably going to say this a bunch is
when you want to detach and you want to
assess what's happening
take a step back write down what's
happening
write down like you got to make a
decision write down
the pros and cons that's why pros and
cons lists are good it's not good
because you don't know it it's good
because it makes you look at it from a
detached perspective you get to see
you keep it all in your mind you're in
it when you take when you write it down
you're like hey here's what's good
here's what's bad oh my gosh the bad
really outweighs the good okay cool
because you were able to take a step
back so writing things down when you
come up to a decision Point hey wait a
second let me just let me just go over
what are the outcomes that I could get
from making this decision
how is this going to go and then
try and answer those questions without
letting your emotions get involved again
not not void of emotions put the
emotions in the calculus
but don't let that drive the entire
decision and then of course make
iterative decisions and then listen to
the feedback so make a little small
decision and direction that you think is
right and then pay attention to what the
feedback is and make sure that it was
the right decision if it's not then
change it
do you and this is kind of a weird
hypothetical question for you do you
let's say
you're
30 30 year old self still in the
military right yeah yeah hell yeah
if that 30 year old Jocko saw your Jocko
right now and would like watch you and
do whatever would would the 30 year old
Jocko be like oh [__] he's a different
person or would he be like okay he's
just like older and wiser I think he'd
be like uh yeah the that oh I see the
conclusion of that idea the way it
developed I see like it's kind of cool
like when I look back at my career in
the military yeah
I don't say you know from a leadership
perspective
here's this horrible thing that I did
and it didn't work yeah usually I'm like
hey here's what I did and this is why I
did it and it still makes sense and that
goes back to when I was 30 years old now
there's things I go ah you know what
could have done that better but I can
see that the trajectory of the way I was
thinking was just not fully formulated
yet yeah but I wasn't doing anything
that was like 180 out yeah you know it
was like oh yeah I really hadn't I
really hadn't quite gotten to this
conclusion yet yeah or I hadn't evolved
that thought pattern yet but it was
going in the right direction so I think
if my 30 year old self would go oh yeah
I can see where that where you got that
from yeah yeah that makes sense
something along those lines because I
mean I kind of remember and I'm sure
it's like you know the Slow Burn of you
changing in whatever way you change
since even before you know back back in
the day when we were like training I was
competing and you were
to me it feels like you're the same
person like literally the same talk
trash person except now you
talk about leadership too you know like
a site but yeah and what's funny is when
you and I were training I was talking
about leadership just not to you yeah
like I mean I was already
you know that's
that's what I was doing yeah
um do you know and I think I told you
this
actually you already know this because
you were part of it the first video I
made for money was with you actually the
first like five videos I mean but um
you were talking about leadership to
some teachers it was like we were making
a DVD or something I remember and uh it
was for teachers and I so I came across
that all those files and I was listening
to it and it's all like underdeveloped
Echelon front stuff oh for sure it's so
funny you're all young
but anyway my point is yeah like you it
doesn't seem like you changed at all no
and like the principles that we talk
about like when you're talking about
that
those principles are the same yeah same
thing
um there's not been there might be like
I have might have a better way of
explaining something showing a different
angle for sure oh yeah but your way you
are actually are a lot different it just
doesn't seem it doesn't feel like it to
me like day to day but yeah if I were to
if you were to like rewind and even
watching those videos I'm like oh this
is like young Jocko but you're still the
same Jocko but you change a lot but
it's not like I'm comparing it to myself
like when I was like 25 or something bro
my 25 year old style would barely
recognize me well yeah well that's true
I think with everybody and if you like
my 25 year old self was definitely wild
like was a little bit out of control and
was uh
uh a kind of a maniac and I remember
I remember when we were on with uh with
uh Jim conkle and Charlie Plum and they
were like talk these guys are like just
I don't want to use the word saintly but
kind of saintly like heroic dudes yeah
and they were kind of like throwing me
in you know with this sort of uh
elevated kind of
virtue and I was like hey guys I just
want to make sure like I was a maniac
when I was younger and so let's not get
too crazy with that stuff I remember
that but uh but yeah I mean the the
principles and also you know you explain
something and then you explain it again
and you you see oh that was a little bit
better so you get better at explaining
stuff over time especially going from
explaining stuff to guys in the teams
where you're just using pure
military examples and then as I worked
with more and more companies like oh
here's another civilian example here's
another business example there's a
family example and you start to be able
to be able to tap into these other uh
ways of explaining things that are that
are
easier for some people to understand
makes sense yeah so there you go
uh next one
[Music]
thoughts on how your concept of the game
matches and or contradicts uh Simon
cynics finite or infinite infinite game
concept and yeah that's that's a good
question obviously you
using the term game and there's going to
be let's see where that ends up and and
one thing that's interesting about this
is that idea of finding finite versus
infinite games is actually from a guy
named James cars who's an American
philosopher uh academic guy from NYU and
he wrote a book
in 1987 that's called finite and
infinite infinite games
uh uh but as far as the concept goes
it's not so much that
they match or they contradict what we've
been talking about
it's it's not that they match or they
contradict uh so to give you the
definition here a finite game is like
any game that has
parameters around it so I always say
chess like chest you have 64 squares
you've got 16 pieces per side they can
only the pieces can only move in certain
directions right that's a finite game
basketball
uh there's a court there's a ball
there's a number of steps you can take
when you're not dribbling there's a
height of the basket there's a number of
points that you get for a shot when you
make it depending where you are so so
all those things are those are finite
games
and what one of the reasons like uh that
I originally thought of this
myself
I'm not trying to say I thought of the
idea was
uh chess I heard I think Lex Friedman
maybe it was Lex but someone talking
about the fact that
that
a computer can win in chess because it's
a finite game so there's no number of
moves and if you can you can get that
thing to run out the the eventualities
of each move and come to the best move
and it can beat a human
infinite games that have no rules
they're a computer might not be able to
win because it's not going to be able to
do something that's totally unexpected
it's not going to have the creativity
that's needed now look we got AI common
and chat gpg and all this stuff so it's
gonna but it's gonna take some sort of
really revolutionary technology for a
machine to be a
human in an infinite game an infinite
game is like life right there's no rules
you can move you a total war
Total War this is a war where you're
like this is for our survival which
means we're going to do whatever it
takes is right there's no rules for as
long yeah for as long as it takes no
rules
street fighting for survival
like that's sort of an infinite game
because if you grab a bottle you can
smash it on the dude's head and cut his
throat open uh if you get a chance to
slam them their face down if you have a
weapon like it's sort of just hey
whatever you got you can bring it into
the game
and so you could have a computer that's
like oh I'm gonna I will the first move
I would do would be a throat punch
and then cool I put two bullets inside
because I was carrying a gun like I win
infinite game yeah
so
finite games and here's the thing finite
games are generally the smaller games
and infinite games are the bigger ones
so what you want to win what you want to
win at is the infinite game and by the
way this
for me
life is an infant game obviously you can
go anywhere but more important to me is
there's degrees in between finite and
infinite right that is that most games
most games have some level of rules
and where those rules are
you can have some games are very strict
some games are very very very loose
there's very limited rules uh business
has rules business has laws
but you can actually go and you can
change and you can disrupt like that's
the big thing right when I disrupt the
industry yeah it's because you were
playing a finite game making your widget
and all of a sudden I realized that I
could make my widget that does something
radically different to yours and what
yours does and all of a sudden you're
out of you're out of business man yeah
so
when you can recognize that
when you can recognize what the rules
are
and generally figure out okay those
rules apply but do I have to follow them
and um
the same thing with like families like
there's a wide there's a wide variety of
ways people live as families right and
just take a City versus hey this family
lives in a city this family lives in a
farm this family lives in a van and
Surfs Up and Down the California coast
they don't have jobs they have
whatever they sell bracelets on the
Seawall that's the real thing like
there's families that that's what they
do they surf and they sell bracelets on
the sea wall right that's a that's now
the other person that's playing the game
is like making a bunch of money working
at a hedge fund trying to afford a place
in Malibu so the family can surf he can
only surf every once in a while who won
the game
who won the game yeah I don't know dude
no this guy's he doesn't just surf at
Malibu there's other dude's in a van
he's going he's going to rencon he's
going up to Santa Cruz he's coming back
down to [__] he's all over the place
this other dude he's actually working
most of the time yeah and by the way
when he's getting an opportunity to Surf
he's kind of at Malibu because that's
where he invested all this money into a
house there
so who won that game
well if you take the infinite game well
well what was the goal was the goal to
make money or was the goal to surf
so I think the important thing here is
yeah there's infinite games and yes
there's uh finite games I think the
important thing is to make sure you
understand what the rules are and if
possible figure out if there's a way
that you can disrupt those rules
overcome those rules break those rules
for lack of a better word look if
there's a legal rule that you're gonna
get arrested for you're gonna lose the
game that's not what I'm talking about
but if you can figure out a way to
revolutionize
the way something is being done like you
know you always hear that story about
the freaking guy that figured out a
better way to do the high jump
right father fosberry flop this guy
changed the game yeah right he didn't he
didn't he he changed he viewed the sport
and figured out a way to do that that's
within the rule the technical rules but
it's way outside the the physical
standards of the way the game was played
totally different
that's a good example
so don't be limited by the rules see if
you can see I don't know another thing
is see if there's a bigger game you can
play
kind of what we just talked about like
oh you're a bartender or you're a a
bouncer and you're the head bouncer is
there a bigger game you can play yeah
you can you can open your own bar okay
well that's kind of cool now you're not
worried about the hierarchy of the
bouncers now you're in the next level
game but then the next level game is
gonna do franchises well now you got a
bunch of these you see what I'm saying
so I'm always looking and you should
always look for
if that's what you want
is there a bigger game that you can play
and don't get stuck in a game that you
could possibly be losing we could just
be playing a bigger game
um
yeah if you're trying you know you're
trying to be the best restaurant in the
best cook in your restaurant why not
just open your own restaurant try to be
the best electrician so you can get
promoted
and manage a crew well why not just
start your own company that being said
what if you are an electrician but you
what you really want to do is focus on
your family
cool then you stay working at a bigger
company because no one call you know
what you know who they call when
something goes wrong and you own a
business they call you it's your
business I own a lot of businesses man
the calls come in 24 7.
I realize that when we opened Victory
MMA and fitness I was like oh there's
something wrong at the oh instructor
didn't show up cool I'm on my way you
know like that's the way it's going yeah
so
that's uh the way that I think that
works
um
with the finite I don't think so my
point is I I don't think it matches or
contradicts
uh what James cars said about finite and
infant and what what Simon Seneca he
talks about it as well Simon Seneca does
he talks about the finite infinite game
concept
but this stuff what we're saying doesn't
match or contradict is just part of it
it's just part of it
um next Quest
this is also from Levick mix
how do you with intention periodically
check your progress within the game
you're playing look you got to detach
you got to take a step back you got to
track what's happening you got to write
down your goals and see where you're at
in order to do that you better schedule
it because Time Slips by and next thing
you know you look up and you've been in
the same game for nine years and you
realize you haven't been making progress
so you need to schedule those reviews
periodically
once every quarter where am I at
in the military they in a military they
have a position called future operations
which is someone that focuses on the
future
you have to put someone there because if
you don't put someone focusing on the
future then everyone's just focuses on
what's going on right now so pay
attention to that
[Music]
um
the same thing that we have to do with
our lives you have to become you have to
you have to set aside time and make
yourself the reviewing officer
of your progress otherwise you'll look
up in four years and you'll realize you
haven't moved and you hadn't made
progress
next one
how do you know which games are
important ones and which ones you can
ignore again real quick you gotta okay
you've got to understand what you value
this is important because we talked
about return on investment we talked
about what you need to put in we talk
about what you're going to get out you
actually have to be honest with yourself
about what you value
and you should probably write down what
you value because if you value money or
you value property or you value family
or you value friends or you value free
time or you value surf trips to to Baja
and that's what you you better write
that down
because otherwise you might be per
playing a game where what you're getting
rewarded with isn't something that you
value hey we're going to give you a
promotion a new title I don't give a
[__]
right hey we're going to give you a new
uh freaking BMW company car I don't care
I want a BMW company car I want to surf
or I want to do Jiu-Jitsu so so make
sure you know so if you want to know
which games are important ones and which
ones you should ignore you need to
figure out what you value
and then run the ROI and the risk to see
if you're getting what you value from
this game
Kobe
Sab
next question he says I stopped lying to
myself about my past my regrets and my
failures
what then do I need to try to make up
for lost time or is it just about
mindset going forward
uh
uh well we all should try and make up
for lost time problem is we can't
it's already gone
it's already gone the lost time is gone
it doesn't matter
so no we're not going to focus on that
we are going to go forward doing as much
as we possibly can
if you focus on the past and you focus
on the lost time and you focus on the
regrets
you're wasting time and energy on
things that don't help you and don't
move you forward
so we're not doing that
good thing you stop lying yourself good
job
you know you made some mistakes you made
some adjustments move forward that's
what we're doing
next one J
if games are about winning
what is the best way to set metrics for
winning the game and how important
would that be
if games are about winning what is the
best way to set metrics for winning the
game and how important would that be
well look
the biggest problem here that we're
talking about is that people don't know
that there's a game being played once
you recognize that there's a game being
played then yeah you got to Define what
winning is going to look like
and you do that by detaching and looking
at it
and again going back to understanding
what you actually value
and once you know what you value and
once you see
what winning looks like then you write
down the objectives of what that winning
is and then you figure out what the
strategy and tactics are to achieve
those objectives and Victory
just like Land Navigation one of the
earlier podcasts we did you have to know
where you're going you have to know
where you're going if you don't know
where you're going you got issues and
then you got to track your progress and
see where you are and then see where you
are in relation to where you're trying
to get to
again you have to Define winning
you have to set the metrics because for
Echo winning might be
getting to ski 100 days a year or
getting to snowboard sorry bro 100 days
a year
for me winning might be making a ton of
money
so we're doing two different things
so you have to figure out what winning
is
in order to figure out that out you have
to know what you value
next one
um this is from Zach heedly Headley
possible to address being taken
advantage of by those who know the game
better
it's a tough lesson but it happens often
especially to young people
can you get taken advantage of by people
who know the game better
a hundred percent
a hundred percent that's why we're
talking about this
because there's nothing worse than being
in a game
with someone that knows the game and you
don't you know or they know the game
better than you or you don't recognize
that you're in a game
so when you get no fight with someone
that knows Jiu Jitsu and you don't you
get smashed
we came home from deployment
and
There Was You Know discussions and
debates about what we were doing and the
types of mission we were doing and what
there was one particular senior officer
and
I told Stoner and Leif I said hey do not
get into a debate with this guy
about our deployment
and they were like why not and I was
like because he'll beat you
he'll beat you in a bit he'll beat me
like I'm not going to debate this stuff
with him he he does what he does he's
one of those people that goes around and
when you step into the arena with
someone that debates all the time you're
not going to do well
it's like when you see the college kid
getting a debate with Ben Shapiro and
he's got 74 facts that he rattles off
because he had this argument at nine
other places in the past two weeks
so they're getting in the ring with him
it's not you know like they're not it
doesn't end well
um so
that's why you have to do an honest
assessment of yourself
and you have to recognize that if
someone is beating you in the game and
you can't contend with them you better
find an exit strategy to get out of that
game
unless you go okay you know I'm gonna
take some hits here but I'm Gonna Learn
that's okay as long as you recognize
that and you don't get taken advantage
of the point where you get left you know
left for dead
hmm
next one's from Logan Buell
b-u-h-l how often should you be
assessing if you're winning the long
game
how should you view the small games that
seem meaningless that involve or impact
look we should be thinking strategic all
the time all the time we should be
thinking about the long game all the
time and we should not be playing games
that don't move you towards this
strategic goal
does this mean don't
don't uh ever watch a TV show because
it's not helping your strategic goal
well no if you if you need a little down
time and the TV show helps you relax
cool go ahead watch your freaking show
but that's not a game right that's a
break and it's a strategic it's a
tactical break that's gonna actually
give you you know allow you to refresh
your mindset and be ready for work and
blah blah now look if you're watching
freaking uh Netflix six hours a day you
got issues yeah we're not doing that no
so you should be thinking all the time
this is very this is a really good
question of course we addressed this
question a lot
think about the games that you're
playing
and if you're playing games that don't
help your big game your strategic game
you should not be wasting time with them
that's it
all of your games that you're playing
should help your long-term strategic
goals
and and look if you got time and you
happen to love freaking backgammon
and you get some satisfaction by playing
backgammon and you want to go play that
literal game and you do it you know once
in uh two hours on Sundays with your
little friends cool there's nothing
wrong with that that's cool have fun
with that
that's fine I'm not talking about that
I'm talking about your
doing things
you're going out Thursday Friday
Saturday night going out looking for a
girl going out looking for a dude right
and that's what you're doing Thursday
Friday you're drinking yeah but you're
in that game
you're wasting money you're hurting your
health
and by the way if you think you're going
to meet the love of your life
there's better ways
than in the pub
no I did happen to meet my wife
[Laughter]
so I guess there's a little except maybe
you know but we're not going to dedicate
we're gonna be careful about this one
we're gonna be careful about that one
yeah we're gonna be careful hey at a
certain point the ROI right okay so this
is what will happen
you do but you've been doing this
Thursday Friday Saturday night drinking
spending money
a year
two years two years you're looking
around going hold on a second here man
three years you're like wait a second I
haven't made any progress
then it's time to make assess what the
hell you're doing
so those tactical games that you're
playing they've got to support your
long-term strategic goals
that's it a long game I like the idea of
uh like little uh like you mentioned
backgammon right where which is funny I
don't know that's a total Jocko example
I don't even like I don't even
understand backgammon yeah it's a weird
board with like the long triangles on it
right yeah yeah they're it's fun but no
a lot of those especially the old school
like board games they're actually good
little micro like exercises for your
mind so like you know you you know you
subscribe to Dr Luke right yeah Luke on
Instagram on his thing so he he he man
he'll put out some really good stuff
little tidbits right so one of them was
this uh thing about balance where he's
like yeah just work on your ballot and
they think he's like on a curb or
something I don't know I forget what he
was doing but he was like just talking
about balance physical your physical
balance your proprioception just about
yeah so I was like yeah if you improve
that that decreases all cause mortality
oh just maintaining you know that that
it has a lot to do with like you know
your your neurotransmitters and your
your neurons and stuff like that in your
brain I don't know above my whole thing
but nonetheless he explains it real
simple and it's like man if you think
about it especially those old school
games like that's kind of what they do
if you if that's your down time like
backgammon it's like wow that's kind of
like running numbers in your head the
other strategy there's math there's like
all these little things that give your
brain this good extra these this good
essentially exercise for your brain
again all those things all those things
are important uh you know learning new
things they say that's really important
you know just for keeping your mind
fresh yeah um now if if you're me if
you're stressed out and you need to know
you know the current champ of backgammon
you know and you're following his life
and maybe that could go into toxic you
know the toxic zone for sure as far as
bro if there's someone that's wrecked
their life playing backgammon I want to
meet him
is there someone that went too hard in
Backgammon yeah so I think I think like
in a way it's kind of it's a lot like
surfing is you know when you take a
break from the grind you know stuff that
you need to break from and then you go
like do something like surfing where
it's obvious although surfing is
conducive to your life it's not like
sitting on the couch watching reality
it's healthy or something on your
balance exactly right but playing games
searching games are the same exact thing
just more for your brain what about
video games well depends on what video
game
they say you go deep you can go deep
looking into that you'll see you'll find
all kinds of benefits with certain kinds
of games any kind of games are good for
you video games I don't know I didn't go
that deep but every once in a while
you'll see little articles
that was the least depth ever yes sir
yes sir that's true but no you know you
can like find articles or whatever
um that will say oh benefits of playing
video games they don't have like you
know hand eye this and that and then you
know then you find out yes it's certain
kinds of games and then you have all
these secondary uh uh benefits as well
like you know especially the like the
shooter games that you're connected to
your friends or whatever and other like
you know towns or whatever over the
internet you ever play that stuff no
yeah I guess there's a little secondary
benefits of that social yeah yeah yeah
like that yeah that was weird during
covid when kids were like
the parents were saying hey don't play
video games all day and they're like but
this is the only way I have friends
right yeah that was a thing yeah yeah we
I don't have a video game like console
at my house so that wasn't happening at
my house because we don't have that
stuff but other parents were saying that
to their their kids they were talking to
me about it like well they feel bad with
your kids not with your kids playing
video games like my kids don't play
video games yeah because we don't have
the thing yeah yeah but and not to say
that that's ideal I'm you know not
necessarily no maybe it was bad maybe I
should have given them more social
connection but you know come on well
yeah I don't think you can then again I
don't know bro I'm not a psychologist
you know this about me that where I I
but I do think that social connection is
gonna be most optimized person to person
I would think that's why there's more
students through a screen that's why the
Jiu Jitsu is good I think that's one of
the many many many benefits of it yes
it's weird man Jiu Jitsu is connected
yeah big time like it's you're like
connected you ever in your different so
I don't know but you're smashing someone
like and they're smashing you yeah it's
it's a it's a radical thing so you know
when you meet someone and like you shake
their hand or whatever and then let's
say you're just standing somewhere it's
like you don't know I'm that good so
you're kind of trying to keep your
boundaries you know the bubble you know
the you know the bubble right you're
what do you call it personal personal
space yeah yeah I know
but you know when you meet someone new
you want to respect personal space a
little you're more sensitive to that I
guess you know bro when you roll with a
guy in Jiu Jitsu like it kind of just
it's like they don't even you don't even
have a buffer anymore you don't have
personal space even like when you're not
rolling it's funny so like like you or
like the guys who I always roll with you
Greg Noah like these guys like I
remember one time I was talking to Noah
and I was like bro I'm really close to
Noah right now it's almost like I
couldn't engage it because I'm so used
to rolling with them you know so like
the personal space is like completely
gone and I think it's in a good way but
I guess that could depend on who you are
yeah Jack
all right so yes long game all the time
uh Caleb Smith five four seven how do I
how how do how do you know how do I know
when it's time to quit the game what are
the symptoms of a game played that will
ultimately lead to the inevitable loss
of time money uh go it goes back to
where we talk about Roi be honest honest
assessments this is the sunk cost
fallacy right this is exactly what you
brought up earlier
um
okay so again some of these questions
are a little bit repetitive but I want
to add some items to them this one here
if you want to know when it's time to
quit the game and what are the symptoms
it can be good in some scenarios to set
up triggers
for action and this is the example of
this is like you know when guys are
climbing a mountain like Mount Everest
or whatever and they say hey if we
haven't gotten to this point by 10
o'clock in the morning we're turning
around and going back there's no we're
not debating it there's no there's no
emotion around it 10 o'clock if we're
not here we'll turn around we're going
back down
you can do that with
the game that you're going to get
involved in
you can hey I'm gonna only spend this
amount of money I'm only gonna spend
this amount of time
I'm gonna at least if I'm not making
this kind of return on investment like
hey I'm gonna start driving you know
Uber at night and that way I can get
some more money you know for for my down
payment on my house
well then you realize that your Roi
driving around your Uber is not as much
as you thought it was going to be hey
I'm not even meeting the minimums this
isn't working I'm not going to do it
so figure out what the minimum required
return is figure out how much time
you're going to invest and put a cap on
that figure out how much money you're
going to invest and put a cap on that
and then you and then you have the
actions in places you're going to take
so when that happens that event gets
triggered hey I'm going to you know
invest in uh trying to start up this
little company if I haven't you know if
I don't have 20 clients by the first
three months obviously there's not a
market for it and I'm gonna stop okay
cool
and then you stick with it look if you
get to 19 you're like well I'm close
Okay cool you know you can you can make
a little adjustment but if you're 13 and
it's been three months and you thought
you're gonna have 20.
then you've made a bunch of adjustments
trying to figure out the market and
you're not there okay you need to walk
away so
that would be uh the thing to set up so
that you recognize the symptoms prior to
because otherwise if they don't have
triggers in place
that's how you end up at the top of
Everest you're out of oxygen and it's
freaking dark and you're gonna die
that's how you end up without any money
left in your bank account and you don't
have a successful business and now you
gotta sell your house
this is how it happens you don't put
triggers in place
and it causes problems
uh next one
[Music]
or maybe it's Chad idia
what direction you go if you realize the
games you are playing are unwinnable but
you don't have the ability to leave and
if you did you don't know the game to
take on next asking for a friend
uh listen
when we get into a game that's
unwinnable
we don't have the ability to leave okay
we'll figure out an exit strategy you
can't leave a game
right you can figure out okay this job
I've been here forever they pay me good
money but it's absolutely awful I'm
never getting promoted and I don't want
to do it anymore okay
you can't leave tomorrow you can't leave
next week you can't leave in a month but
you can over time a year two years three
years figure out an exit strategy
and
make a move we're not doing Brash moves
right we're not making emotional
decisions we're going to take our time
how to get out of this game and then
also take our time figure out what game
to play next
to do a class on
uh knitting
and you're like dude this is awesome I
love the way this feels to make the
scarf and like I want to do sweaters and
okay we'll go do some more of that maybe
you're gonna end up selling sweaters on
Etsy sure
cool
or you take a knitting class you're like
this is monotonous and I hate it okay
cool well let's take some time to figure
out the new game little iterative
decisions and also multiple
reconnaissance probes
there's so many opportunities out there
in the world
there's so many of them and not all of
them are good opportunities by the way
some of them might seem cool but they're
a lot harder than they look like
some of them are
harder than they look like but they're
not that bad and you can make some good
money and you can be gratified by doing
it
so do multiple reconnaissance like oh
you like knitting cool try a little bit
of knitting you also like making candles
cool make some candles you also like
pouring concrete okay well let's see
what's going on with that
maybe on the weekends you start pouring
a little concrete doing some little
projects for people for real cheap and
you just realize you're good at it maybe
you realize you suck at it which is also
possible
so do reconnaissance of multiple
opportunities that are out there
then you make your decision
and then you have that exit strategy to
execute
next one is from Renee Christine
maybe you can talk about the thought
process you go through in order to turn
something hard into a game yeah when I'm
doing something really hard if I'm going
to find some little achievable goals
little achievable goals that lean
towards uh strategic victory
maybe set up some rewards for me for my
team
and then execute on those little things
I think
that
that mindset of like I'm literally gonna
have fun with this thing that sucks goes
a long way
so I don't have uh that's my process
like oh yeah this sucks you don't know
the thing is this sucks and I'm never
gonna let anybody know that I think it
sucks
yeah
I'm doing something horrible but I'm
never gonna tell anybody and I'm
actually gonna make them think I love it
they're gonna think I'm crazy I kind of
have fun with that that's fun for me I
just turned it into a game that's such a
good game it's a good game so
um
so when I swim in the pool with my kids
and nowadays it's kind of colder than
normal okay look cold that means a lot
of different things to different people
I understand and I'm from cool I saw I
understand that going into the story for
you it's like under 70. so I would say
it's about 55 degrees okay that's cool
yeah so I jump in my daughter can stand
cold like she don't care yeah cold does
not bother her because you think my son
he don't like that oh he doesn't like
cold so we'll jump in and I'll jump in
first and she'll be like is it go I'll
be like oh it's so warm meanwhile I
might throw this [__] it's cool
and I'm like oh it's so warm it's almost
too warm you know like that kind of
right and they're like oh believe and
the more convincing I can be meanwhile
I'm trying not to shiver you know and
it's like it it almost like physically
feels warmer for sure I'm saying like
it's like the game kind of filters in
this the bad stimulus turns it into like
a different stimuli bro that's a good
one right there to act like oh this
isn't even a fair like what I didn't
even notice they would say false
motivation is better than nowhere
because it's kind of true right it's
absolutely true there's a girl a lady
named Gene McGonagall she talks about
gamification it's an actual process
where you take hard stuff you turn them
into little games and you get through
them like you know you thrive whatever
and she did it because she had an
illness I forget the illness and she was
like Hey I'm gonna turn this whole thing
this is my whole recovery process which
was super arduous process I'm gonna turn
this recovery process into a series of
games and that's how she started on the
path of like understanding gamification
but um there's an actual process to it
and it's like apparently it's super
super effective
let's do one more
and then we're gonna we'll go and do
another one um because I got a bunch
more of these things to cover but let's
do one more this is kind of a a little
bit of a chunky one
this is from Santos Carlos III
when solid honorable hard-working men
refuse to play the game because quote
there shouldn't be a game
how to navigate the dichotomy and Dogma
around progression as tenure
versus progression through experience
this is a little bit tricky of of a
question to understand but I'm going to
do my best with it and there's he says
context some of the most knowledgeable
talented and experienced people I've
worked with
were both years and decades younger in
tenure
however they spent so much time
consistently exposing themselves to
challenging problems they progressed
well beyond the 99 percentile anyone
their age
so that's the that's the Dogma around
progression is tenure versus progression
through experience
so it's time versus it's really about
effort because experience is sort of
wrapped around time so let's answer that
uh
people that engage and train and
practice and challenge themselves will
get better than people that don't
the and so there's a Dogma he's like
the Dogma around that and I think what
he's trying to ask is like the negative
what the negative impression of people
that work really hard don't have much
time but they're excelling that's what
I'm getting from this question I hope
I've I hope I've got it
uh
the reason that that sometimes hurts
people that are like let's say Echo
checked on board he hasn't been here for
very long but he's really kind of
kicking ass and yet I kind of hold it
against him why is that there's a decent
chance
that echo echo has the he's exposing
himself he's training hard he's putting
himself in challenging positions so he's
learning a lot he's doing really well
but Echo doesn't have the maturity and
tact to remain humble
so you end up creating an antagonistic
relationship with me because I'm looking
at you like oh he's just one of these
people that's trying so hard and I'm
gonna look for every little opportunity
to hurt your progress
so
if you want to overcome the way that
works
or you want to help someone you know you
get some new guy on your team that
checks in that is really doing a good
job but it's rubbing people the wrong
way
just talk to him about staying humble
and talk to them about the importance of
building good relationships
and that will be helpful
so
I hope that answers the first question
again these are a little bit uh
a little bit I didn't quite fully
understand them the the second question
is an observation more than a question
but it's interesting how many missed the
opportunity of chasing forward-looking
asymmetrical opportunities opportunities
with limited risk but potential huge
upsides and a relative solid likelihood
of success why is that so why do people
Miss opportunities
that have low risk and I think there's a
couple reasons number one is failure to
recognize like they just don't see them
and because they don't detach and so the
opportunities right in front of them
they don't see it
you know that's the old experiment where
the freaking gorilla goes walking
through the people that are throwing the
basketball yeah and like no one sees it
because they're in they're watching the
counting the numbers and they don't see
this obvious thing so there's a failure
to recognize because people don't detach
enough
and then on top of that sometimes they
see the opportunity but they don't want
even a limited risk
they don't want to take even a small
risk with a big reward they don't want
to take it we say that all the time
humans don't like
humans tend to not want to take action
and humans tend not to want to take risk
not all humans let me let me rephrase
that there are many humans that don't
like to take action and there are many
humans that don't like to take risk
and so when they're presented an
opportunity but they're going to have to
do something a little bit different and
they're gonna have to take risk they're
just like I'm going to keep doing what
I'm doing
so I think that is why that happens
so there you go Santos I hope I was able
to kind of
get those for you and uh with that it's
a game for this time I guess we're gonna
have to do one more podcast about the
game the game the games here we are in
the meantime if you want to play the
health game the fitness game the being
better game the stronger faster better
game better get in the Jocko fuel game
jockoffuel.com we got Mulk
which is we got ready to drink milk
right now which is fire different level
yeah fire fire slaps oh it slaps big
time you like you you open your fridge
maybe you could you know have a piece of
steak maybe you could have some uh
mozzarella sure right hell yeah
mozzarella mozzarella with the virgin
olive oil on it oh what those little
things yeah yeah it's a little basil on
it yeah that's the kind of thing I think
yeah Sarah made those the other day it's
good like two days in a row yeah those
are good but there's a um look
I'm gonna put myself on report for being
lazy yes sir but there's like you know
you're cutting basil leaves whatever
you're getting the oil out you're making
a plate that Mulk is just sitting there
ready yeah 30 grams of protein ready to
go down the hatch tasty tastes better
than mozzarella
yeah I mean this is a given so we got
the ready drink milk we had the powder
milk we got joint Warfare super krill
um Cold War got it all and we got the
energy drinks yeah we got the energy
drinks
so the but these aren't the normal
energy drinks that make you sick and
make you diabetic and are poison no
these are not those in the store are
these in the health
Department bro this is a good point the
you when you go into a store when you go
to Vitamin Shop well vitamin shop
they're there and pretty easy to find
but when you go into like a military
commissary you go into Hannaford you go
into HEB or Murphy's or or Meyer
in some of these stores they're in like
the health and wellness section they're
not in the energy drink section so just
be advised yeah that's kind of
interesting right what's the I mean the
conundrum right from a store standpoint
or from a what do you call customer
stuff from a customer well from a store
standpoint they're like oh well this
energy drink will put over in the energy
drink section because it's it's all
these are the same right but we also
have a health and wellness things that
make you better yeah and we know where
this belongs yeah so they're kind of
right they're right either way they're
right it would be nice if they could
give the consumer the visibility on like
oh I have a healthy option that I can go
to here yeah well I guess it kind of
depends right well ideally both but you
know then logistically right I'm kind of
kind of but yes look if I go in I don't
know I don't know about the ghost yet I
go in I just want an energy drink you
know I want the sugar-free I'm just
gonna go you know I go and then I see
the new ghost sugar free all the good
stuff it's good for you it's like I'm
choosing now and all day all day energy
drink
but at the same time if I'm like bro I'm
I'm not down for energy drink now I'm
down for the healthy one healthy stuff
the kombucha or whatever I don't know
where the hell other healthy things but
anyway and then they're gonna see that
boom they're gonna grab that one as well
see I'm saying so they got to be there
so I don't know yeah the hard thing is
is like you get into this business
that [__] all that shelf space is like
accounted for it means something it's
like every little slot that they have in
any of these stores has value there's a
value that slot so they're like hey look
oh we can't put you in both the way you
want the horse you want this to be when
we put in the meat section too yeah you
know what I'm saying the produce yeah
it's yeah so it should be the produce
section yeah
so I'm looking for orange juice right
but this the uh what we got the freshly
squeezed that's what I'm looking for if
you go in the juice section
I don't my wife does I don't but you go
in the juice section there's three juice
sections by the way in the supermarket
huh yeah you don't know that because you
don't got the smell right now but so you
go in the juice section with a grit um
like in the refrigerator-ish section so
there's your uh what do you call them I
don't know I forget the brands offhand
but Welch's there's some Welches in
there Tropicana Tropicana yes Simply
Orange simply grapefruit all these
juices right there's that section it's
the refrigerator or you can go to the
cranberry juice the cran grape the crab
cran Apple okay lemon juice that's in a
hole that's in the aisle it's a
different section here and then if you
want the freshly squeezed oh you're over
like the organic area yeah like it's
like in the fruit and vegetable section
kind of it's weird right so it's like
it's kind of one of those things you
kind of got to know what you're there
for and know who you're providing for at
the same time and we got to do a better
job of letting you know to take a look
around maybe ask the cler the stock
person ask somebody say Hey where's this
where's the where's the go at where's
the Jocko fuel at so there you go you
can get into jocofuel.com you can get a
Wawa you can get all these places You
Know You Can Get It Go Get It make
yourself better originusa.com
geez
boots
jeans
rash guards
all made in America not made by slaves
yeah there's actual slavery in the world
right now it's happening literally so
literally so Pete our boy Pete was on
Andy frisella uh real AF the podcast
it's really good like and he uh that was
a good podcast by there
um he's he put it a really good way I
don't think I've ever heard this before
um he was like hey yeah you know like
America yeah we ended slavery but
slavery didn't end we just we just
shipped it offshore yeah as I'm saying
so like we're letting the other country
slaves do a lot of the work now I'm like
dang when you think about it probably
it's true oh it's 100 true
it's 100 true
uh we don't want that yeah
we don't want that originusa.com and
slavery that's what we're doing
get on board jeans boots hunt gear the
hunt gear let's face it but you can't
not wear that honey every time I see
your dumbass yeah we're just wearing it
oh yeah yeah that's what we're doing uh
the hunk gear so check that out also
apparently I have a store it's called
Jocko store yeah
uh yeah yeah that's when you want to
represent this whole path The Source
that's what it's called now the source
interesting
um yeah just plain equals Freedom you
know good all these things they
represent certain mindset I guess you
could say I don't know check it out jaka
store that's where you can get some so
we have a shirt Locker as well
Subscription Service different designs a
little bit funner from time to time
sometimes they're darker
but it's a new design every month a
little bit more emotional One Direction
or the other apparently
yeah from time yeah we switch it up for
sure do you feel good when you nail it
sure yeah and you get the good feedback
yeah even for me when I go Yelp yep
that's a good one the answer is yes I do
like that a lot for sure uh
jockostore.com don't forget to subscribe
to the podcast don't forget about Jocko
underground.com
there's a there's censorship there's
control of the platforms there's drama
out there we're not in the drama look
we're doing our job but if somebody
wants to ban us they could do it
tomorrow we don't control their
platforms but we control ours Jocko
underground.com if you want to go check
that out you can listen to this podcast
some other podcasts that we do on there
it costs eight dollars and 18 cents a
month if you can't afford it it's okay
we still want you in the game
email assistance at tacounderground.com
we got a YouTube channel origin USA has
a YouTube channel we've got
psychological warfare flip side canvas
got a bunch of books you know what they
are Echelon front it's our leadership
consultancy and don't forget that we
have online training
we have online leadership training
online Life Training extreme ownership
Academy take ownership of your life go
to extreme ownership.com I'm on there
Mondays doing live q a you want to ask
me a question about your business about
your life about Jiu Jitsu about your
your boss about your employee about your
husband your wife come and ask me
extreme ownership.com
there you go there's a bunch of courses
to take as well and also if you want to
help service members active and retired
you want to help their families gold
star families check out Mark Lee's mom
mama Lee she's got a charity
organization which is awesome and if you
want to donate her you want to get
involved go to America's Mighty Warriors
dot org and don't forget about
another.org heroes and horses
Micah Fink up there and where is he
right now oh he's he's horseback in the
mountains in the wilderness with some
veterans helping find their souls
so go to Heroes and horses.org if you
want to help that out we're on the
interwebs
Echoes that Echo Charles
he's back on Twitter after he freaking
made a rookie mistake it was a hard time
for everybody yeah rookie mistake yeah
big for a computer guy yeah brutal it
can happen to anybody I guess even the
strongest have their moments of fatigue
and you just got mentally distracted
it's a metaphor
legit
hey man what the best of us get caught
would you rather admit would your mother
admit being tired or dumb
I don't know
[Laughter]
all right well Echo Charles is back on
Twitter he feels
like maybe he's lost some of his uh
clout in the social media world because
he has 19 followers now
I'm at Jocko we're like Hey listen when
you go on there just watch out for the
algorithm that's not a game that's going
to help you that's not a game that's
going to help you the algorithm game is
going to win don't let it and uh thanks
to all the military members out there
worldwide protecting our way of life
thank you for your continued service and
thanks also to our police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics EMTs
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol Secret Service all First
Responders thank you for protecting us
here at home and to everyone else out
there remember there's a lot of games
being played
you are playing them
so pick the right games to focus on
don't waste time on games that don't
matter
and when it comes to the games that do
play to win
until next time this is Echo and Jocko
out